last thought about last night's debate
the last third and final presidential
debate we had this interview i think it
was howard kurtz maybe or brian Stelter
one of the media bias show guys
interviewed chris wallace about a month
and a half ago or two months ago and
asked him will you be fact-checking or
keeping the candidates sort of honest
during the debate if they try to lie and
we played the clip and chris walker
chris wallace basically said i am not
there to fact-check Pete others will do
that and it made me wonder well what's
the point I mean you can have you don't
really need a moderator just to ask
questions you can have the questions pop
up on a screen and have a timer that
shuts off people's mics when their time
goes off but I was glad to see that
Chris Wallace in spite of selecting
questions that unbalanced were probably
better questions for Trump although he
did completely bungle many of them badly
big-league as he would say Chris Wallace
did drop a major truth bomb when Donald
Trump tried to deny the reality that
there's a consensus that Russia was
indeed involved in these recent leaks
connected to WikiLeaks and Hillary
Clinton etc Trump tried to flat out deny
it and Hillary Clinton of course said
that that does appear to be the case
Chris Wallace interjected and dropped a
major truth bomb I'm gonna play for you
this two minutes segment we'll hear a
little bit from Trump we'll hear from
Hillary Clinton and we will also hear
from Chris Wallace I think that this was
exactly the right thing for Chris
Wallace to do because Trump was going
above and beyond what the known and
publicly stated and available consensus
is on this issue and of course some
right-wingers say oh Chris Wallace is
being really unfair to Trump here I
don't buy that let's take a look and you
can judge for yourselves 1800 by the way
where they expanded and we didn't 1800
nuclear warheads and she's playing
chicken look from everything I see has
no respect for this person well that's
because he'd rather have a puppet as
president no pop today no problem it's
pretty clear it's pretty clear you won't
admit
the Russians have engaged in cyber
attacks against the United States of
America that you encouraged espionage
against our people that you are willing
to spout the Putin line sign up for his
wish list rake up NATO do whatever he
wants to do and that you continue to get
help from him because he has a very
clear favorite in this race so I think
that this is such an unprecedented
situation we've never had a foreign
government trying to interfere in our
election we have 17:17 intelligence
agencies civilian and military who have
all concluded that these espionage
attacks these cyber attacks come from
the highest levels of the Kremlin and
they are designed to influence our
election I find that deeply disturbing
I think it's no idea until it do you
doubt 17 agencies well Vladimir Putin
then the military and civilian
intelligence professionals who are sworn
to protect us I find that just because
Putin has outsmarted her at every step
of the way
in some questions yes and I would like
to ask you this direct question the top
national security officials of this
country do believe that Russia has been
behind these hacks even if you don't
know for sure whether they are do you
condemn any interference by Russia in
the American election by Russia or
anybody else you condemn their
interference of course I condemn of
course I can I don't know Putin I have
no idea I never met houghton this is not
my best friend but if the United States
got along with Russia wouldn't be so bad
let me tell you Putin has outsmarted her
and Obama at every single step of the
way how child
can you imagine anything more childish
than no you're the puppet Hilary you're
the puppet and I think that this was
interesting in that you actually saw
Donald Trump condemn hypothetical though
he doesn't even agree that it's going on
or at least he's not conceding or
admitting that he believes or
understands that condemn Russian
involvement now of course he completely
sort of milk toasted it by saying oh I
condemn the involvement of any country
in trying to influence American
elections but it was actually
interesting to see him say that although
every critique of Russia and Putin from
Donald Trump it's like pulling teeth
it's like it's so reluctant and it
really tells us a lot about why we
suspect partially the tax returns are
not being released in business business
deals with Russia which Trump of course
has claimed he doesn't have but then
he's also claimed he does have and who
really knows what the truth is right
wingers did not like Chris Wallace's
interjection of that basic fact I
believe Chris Wallace did absolutely
nothing wrong in that segment and just
said no the the facts are that that is
the intelligence consensus given that
what is your opinion will you denounce
will you condemn over all the questions
at the debate last night favorable
questions in terms of topic to Donald
Trump but Chris Wallace moderately fair
in terms of pushing both candidates when
it comes to trying to not answer
questions and overall given what we've
come to expect from anybody associated
with Fox News I think that Chris Wallace
did okay all right let's take a break
there's still much else to discuss I do
want to talk about allegations of voter
fraud and so-called risk rigged
elections more specifically I want to
talk about what's going on in Utah and
much more I'm on Twitter at D Pakman and
remember you can sign up for membership
at david pakman.com slash membership